come on hey i'm peter ruben and i'm
kelly ruben if you watch the show for
Crosby the dog he's not here this week
no but this is still split screen
because there's always more than one
side to every story every movie every
game every TV show or television events
television events like wayward Pines
which started last night on Fox to niche
this very creepy thing and it's got
Terrence Howard as the sheriff of this
creepy town and you seem creeped out
right now yeah so best man is one of my
favorite movies and he was my favorite
thing from that movie and I said oh my
gosh I love Terrence Howard but then
every other thing that I learned about
Terrence Howard the things that
supposedly go on in his personal life
has attitudes towards women all of those
things go and paint my viewership of all
of his work so there's like a big
swirling mass of some real some
performative things but they have all
colored your view when you see him in a
role yes sometimes if all I know about
somebody is the characters or even the
archetypes of the characters they play I
tend to associate those with the
performer themselves like Pinterest
Jenny sleep right yeah knew her on Parks
and Rec is Jean Ralphio sister and she
always plays someone who's either really
selfish or Jeff hubristic or away or
whatever so good at she's great at it
and this of course is because of her
comedy chops but in my tiny pea sized
brain I'm Michael that's where she
really must be I'd like her hey mom and
it wasn't until she was an obvious child
last year and I got a chance to hear her
being herself on talk shows and on
podcast yeah where I realized how unfair
I had been being and now I'm like super
fan so as I guess seeing her three
dimensionally helped in that regard yes
but often for me it makes it worse yeah
and I think we just have so many more
opportunities to see candor and it can
cut both ways one way for you another
way for me but I think you're absolutely
right with social media and so many more
opportunities for us to see celebrities
being kind of candid or unvarnished
there's just a thousand ways for them to
show their ass yes and a thousand ways
to be offended and Terrence Howard found
the perfect way to offend you that's
right but we hope you're not offended by
split screen why would you be we're not
we hope to stick around see us next week